jetzt habe ich ein kind war parat
na ja heute was knapp und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut herzlich
willkommen bei diesem video wie ihr alle
wisst jetzt jeden tag um 19 eventueller
manchmal auch erst um 20 uhr kommt halt
darauf an wie es der mannschaft ab
mittwoch wieder mit kameramann das heißt
ja noch ein bisschen coolere videos
jetzt gerade hier von zu hause oder nur
mit stativ aber ist eigentlich auch gar
nicht so schlimm ich muss sagen ich habe
unter meinem letzten essens videos immer
öfter gelesen allerdings macht man mal
eben was mit vegan oder probleme vegane
sachen aus und ja ich bin ich für alles
offen deswegen machen wir das heute ich
habe mich voll grad mal schauen ich habe
irgendwann mal so ein video gemacht
haben da ging so eine woche vegan also
das war wirklich ein etwas längeres
projekt von mir genau hier ist es eine
worte nur vegan ernähren da war ich auch
in verschiedenen restaurants unterwegs
hat mittlerweile sogar schon über
400.000 klicks um 26.000 dax gab es viel
für nicht also könnt ihr euch ja gerne
anschauen verlinkt ich euch hier nach
ich kann mich noch ganz gut an das video
erinnern und dort haben viele darunter
geschrieben die selber vegan leben das
sich halt nicht wirklich sachen gekauft
habt die jetzt veganer tagtäglich kaufen
weil ich habe in dem video öfter
kritisiert was auch logisch ist und
nachvollziehbar dass die produkte halt
alle deutlich teurer sind als nicht
vegane produkte von daten der eine oder
andere veganer geschrieben dass man das
aber umgehen kann und man wohl produkte
finden kann
die günstig sind deswegen bevor ich im
supermarkt haben irgendwelche veganen
sachen ausgesucht habt ich habe mir erst
mal zwei verschiedene internet blogs von
veganern durchgelesen und ein youtube
video angeschaut von einem veganer also
ich glaube das vegan weil ich auch gerne
in der video beschreibung wo ich mich
über produkte informiert habt die diese
personen kaufen weil dann kann mir
keiner sagen ja alex horst widder sachen
gekauft wie kein veganer ist ich bin
auch wirklich wieder schlauer geworden
in dem ich diese blogs und videos
geschaut habe mir ist aufgefallen wie
viele produkte ist eigentlich doch gibt
die vegan sind die ich auch selber
manchmal ist wo ich aber gar nicht weiß
dass sie begann sind weil ich um ehrlich
zu sein überhaupt nicht darauf achtet
wenn ich dann mal hier so lese was alles
vegan ist die grüne soße bargeld
brötchen tat bitterschokolade tortilla
chips mit sei es sogar diese chips sind
vegan ich zumindest auf dem anderen
veganen blog gelesen als kroketten und
also was ist auch vegan und das wusste
ich um ehrlich zu sein ich hoffe ihr
mich dafür jetzt ausläuft oder nicht ich
weiß es nicht aber ich bin hätte ich das
wusste ich nicht gut kommen wir mal zum
thema also ich habe mir nur sachen
gekauft die ich selber sehr oft esse
nicht vegan und dieser dann halt heute
in veganen die zeige ich euch jetzt mal
wir haben ja als erstes dreikorn
toastbrot und meiner lieblings marke
nein
dann habe ich vegane milch gekauft von
alpro wurst er sich eigentlich nie aber
ich habe mir einfach mal vegan
aufschnitt mitgebracht nach schinken art
bin ich extrem geschadet
hinzu kommen diese moscheen vegan also
regale chip auch ziemlich interessant
war nur joghurt oder vanille pudding
auch von dieser albtraum marke hier
haben wir auf markt brötchen ich glaub
schon dass genau sechs kleine brötchen
entspannt für drei euro entstand so
komme ich etwas so denning was hat der
hat auch ein paar euro gekostet habe ich
auch noch nie gesehen hier haben wir
ritter sport dunkle mandl quinoa
schokolade regalen schmelzkäse hätte ich
auch niemals gedacht dass es so etwas
gibt von simply wie er muss sich ab
könnte auch meine marke seine simple wie
bei alex wie haben standen dann habe ich
noch kokoswasser mitgenommen einfach nur
weil es mich interessiert hat also das
trinke ich jetzt nicht täglich und
worüber ich auch ziemlich verwundert war
die marke nein hat verschiedene kurt
flecker arten die wohl auch alle wiegand
und wurde mir zumindest auf diesem blog
als vegan verkauft ich könnte es jetzt
hier nirgendwo hat auch die regale
gestellt ja dass hier sind um ehrlich zu
sein dann auch schon alle sachen ich
habe insgesamt für alles 23 euro knapp
24 euro bezahlt was schon auf jeden fall
teurer ist als wenn ich dir jetzt nicht
vegan geholt hatte ich habe wirklich nur
sachen gekauft von demir veganer im
internet erzählt haben die hab ich auch
deswegen sagt mir jetzt nicht wieder
unterschiedlich aber nicht gekommen
ok willkommen zurück musste ich an alle
die sich wundern warum diese dinge genau
stehen
ich mag die nicht deswegen also
zumindest nicht so gerne deswegen lasse
ich jetzt einfach mal dass stehen damit
ich immer in den kommentaren leser wer
schaut auch die ganze zeit auf diese
blauen denke ich muss sagen da ich
zurzeit ziemlich bauchschmerzen habe
wegen dem wetter oder so keine ahnung
ist ja bestimmt ganz gut denn das hört
sich ja sehr gesund an
ich meine drei euro mehr ebenso kurz weg
ist wenn ich mir
ticket kaufe bisher auch bei 45 euro der
unterschied ist halt den habe ich aus
dem supermarkt also 3 euro wäre der kauf
sich das sind für drei euro also ich
halte jetzt nur weil ich das viel oder
zu drehen
[Musik]
naja ich habe vor das hätte ich gar
nicht gedacht ich dachte es ist jetzt
ein gesunder seinem gesunder kleiner
drink mal eben für zwischendurch haben
wir auf jeden fall ein harter anfangen
mal gucken ob meine bauschmerzen jetzt
gleich besser oder schlechter als im
problems ist natürlich die frage womit
machen wir weiter
ich habe noch einige sachen zu aussagen
auf den käse bin ich auch sehr gespannt
aber ich würde sagen ich starte hier mit
den tipps der humus chips haben mich
glaube ich zwei euro 49 gekostet oder so
also preis sich eigentlich in ordnung
grenzt sich hat sich nämlich von anderen
chips ab ich bin mal gespannt wie die
schmecken muss ich sagen ich ziemlich
gut erinnern wie stark an diese goldberg
wie hießen jetzt noch mal die heißen
diese scheiß bernd in bombay genau die
schmeckt gegen die so ein bisschen wie
conwert combat ships aber sehr gut was
ich bei chips immer gar nicht weil erst
wenn die zuseher gewürzt sind und diese
sind perfekt also von allen chips die
ich je gegessen habe fallen dir auf
jeden fall in die top-3 kann ich euch im
film toast brot und die brötchen machen
wir zum schluss einfach weil ich gleich
kurz runter muss muss die auf backen und
das tust würde ich sehr gerne thorsten
ok kommen wir zur ritter sport
schokolade die 189 gekostet hat deutlich
teurer als andere ritter sport
schokolade nicht auf jeden fall schon
sehr sehr gut jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ob ich das umhaut
ok also ich muss sagen es ist lecker man
kann es auf jeden fall essen ich bin
aber ehrlich zu euch und ich muss sagen
ich finde das kommt nicht alle nicht
veganer ritter sport schokolade an
irgendwas fehlt mir da einfach dass das
schmeckt für mich nicht 100 prozent wie
gute schokolade so aber trotzdem nicht
schlecht weil ich kann mir auch
vorstellen wenn man das dann erstmal
zwei drei wochen immer ist und gewohnt
ist dass man dann gar nicht mehr so wie
es verlangen hat nach richtiger
schokolade weil man sich dran gewöhnen
aber wenn ich jetzt dieses produkt mit
den chips vergleich schneiden die chips
auf jeden fall besser aber ich habe
immer noch gänsehaut von diesem fall
schon jetzt können wir direkt zum
nachspielen immer das kokoswasser
organik coconut water nehmen da habe ich
mich auch gefragt wieso eigentlich so
was kaum ich habs nur gekauft weil ich
an diesem vegan abtei lang gegangen bin
und hab es einfach mitgenommen weil es
mich so an gelächelt hat ist aber auch
schon ziemlich zu gestaubt also das
stand da wohl schon ein bisschen länger
ich auch gewöhnungsbedürftig da hat
glaube ich 179 gekostet für so ein
kleines fläschchen hier das gab es auch
im groß das hat dann über vier euro
gekostet also da muss ich auch sagen
schmeckt hier überhaupt nicht bestimmt
andere vegane drinks die deutlich besser
sind wobei ich was drinks angeht jetzt
gar nicht so geschaut habe brücke voll
zum brot kommen habe ich natürlich jetzt
erstmal noch die cornflakes und die
milch milch mit sojamilch genaue
contrexx habe ich früher jeden morgen
gegessen in letzter zeit eigentlich gar
nicht mehr so viel
deswegen bin ich mal gespannt ob die
mich jetzt überzeugen könnt mit der soja
milch in köln gibt es an influenza café
das heißt in die café bar oder so da bin
ich mir mit meiner freundin weil die
dahin will ich muss da nicht hin und sie
bestellt dort immer so soja kaffee und
wenn ich das probiere denke mir ach du
heilige scheiße was ist denn da drin war
jetzt kommt für mich um welten nicht an
den normalen kaffee also die richten
sich schon verdammt gut ich habe genau
das ist heute früher einmal gegessen von
dieser bekannten cornflakes marke mit
dem namen ich einen so auch wenn jetzt
wahrscheinlich im hintergrund ab und zur
geräusche von meiner eltern hört die
irgendwie immer hier was zu tun haben
wenn ich ausgerechnet ein video drehen
also ich glaube es würde mich nicht
überzeugen aber ich versuche
unvoreingenommen an die sache
heranzugehen
das wohl gut hätte ich nicht gedacht
aber das ist wirklich verdammt gut denn
jetzt auch noch die möglichkeit wäre
alter das war richtig neues also wie
schon gesagt so sojamilch dass ich
eigentlich dass das gar nicht mein fall
ist aber das liegt wohl dann in diesem
café mal daran weil es so mit kaffee
vermischt wird und so kein plan jetzt
habe ich aber eine ganz andere meinung
also in kombination mit den cornflakes
schmeckt richtig gut ich kann mich auch
überhaupt nicht daran erinnern dass ich
jemals begannen joghurt probiert habe
ich habe glaube ich auch keinen veganen
joghurt in einem eine woche wegen
experiment gegessen
deswegen bin ich jetzt auch mal hier
gespannt ob mich da überzeugt ok alters
sind damit von der konsistenz her ich
hoffe wir können das ein bisschen sehen
die das auf jeden fall schon mal ganz
anders aus als andere war eine junge der
ist viel flüssiger so okay let's go das
ist schwierig
ist in ordnung jetzt wenn man sich so
ein bisschen mehr gewöhnt hatte erst ein
darüber gar nicht gut aber es schmeckt
auf jeden fall krass anders als
richtiger richtiger pavillon aber das
beste sache da glaubt man kann sich auf
jeden fall dran gewöhnen wenn man das
wirklich möchte also der vanille
geschmack ist ziemlich intensiv die
konsistenz gefällt mir halt nur
irgendwie überhaupt nicht trotzdem würde
ich sagen ist in ordnung und wie schon
gesagt ich glaube man kann nicht dran
gewöhnen
jetzt bin ich aber mal gespannt wie geht
es mal kurz die brötchen aufbacken
und auch das toastbrot mit fächern hat
einen veganen butter wäre auch nicht
schlecht gewesen habe ich leider
vergessen dann werden wir dass man mit
käse und schinken belegen und wir sehen
uns dann gleich wieder um elbe starten
hier mit dem 3 controls ist schon im
toaster und runter und dazu kommt dann
auch dieses petit bulle usa auf brötchen
vom stetigen aufbau zum aufbacken
genau ich habe diesen käse gerade schon
darfst ausgelegt der soll jetzt da
zerlaufen ich würde aber trotzdem mal
kurz so probieren wollte der stinkt halt
extrem nach also so ganz intensiv
richter nach käse okay okay leute ich
bin soweit fertig was mir aufgefallen
ist das war echt lange im ofen aber der
käse verläuft nicht also kaum zumindest
bisschen schade aber vielleicht macht ja
trotzdem und hier haben wir das auf
gebackene brötchen opel weitergeht es
war halt also ich würde erstmal sagen
auch schneiders erstmal hier auch mal
gucken wie das von innen aussieht oder
es schneidet sich gül ist also es
richter auf jeden fall sehr lecker
erinnert mich irgendwie an so ein brot
was ich öfter mal ein pfleger kriegel
zumindest langstreckenflug letztes jahr
nach amerika hatte ich glaube ich
genauso ein brötchen hier haben wir
jetzt das dreikorn toastbrot mit legalen
schmelzkäse drauf und wie das schmeckt
keine ahnung ich hab mir irgendein käse
schon mal so probiert das tostberg
absolut in ordnung
der käse überzeugt mich halt irgendwie
gar nicht schmeckt gar nicht für mich
schmeckte riet er riecht nach käse aber
schrecklich marquise wenn ich einfach so
ein bisschen schleifen ich also an alle
veganer die das jetzt schauen
tut mir leid und ich böse aber
vielleicht kann man sich da auch dran
gewöhnen ich weiß es nicht schmeckt mir
allerdings nicht so gut wie normale sind
aber wir hatten ja auch schon genug
sachen die mich überzeugt haben dann
haben wir jetzt beschloss das vegane
brötchen mit wir gaben auftrieb
nachschicken art gericht aber schon ein
bisschen nach schinken also und nach
noch irgendwas ich kann das nicht
definieren also let's go ich bin extrem
gespannt
wahrscheinlich mehr ganz so zusammen mit
dem brötchen schmeckt man wirklich gar
nicht dass der schinken kein echter
schinken deshalb im vergleich zum care
ist dass ich werde noch in die mich
überzeugt sagt tanja empfehlen probiert
das mal als nicht veganer also ich bin
jetzt eigentlich auch schon durch ich
muss sagen es war wirklich sehr
interessant für mich das mal
auszuprobieren ganz vegan zu leben kann
ich mir mehr als zu sein nicht
vorstellen aber vegetarisch eventuell
schon dazu gebe ich euch auf jeden fall
demnächst mal ein paar infos auch wenn
ich super super gerne mal einen burger
essen oder ein steak kann ich mir aber
auch vorstellen dass ich mir das easy
abgewinnen kann ich hoffe dieses ziel
deutlich gefallen geht mir doch noch
oben schreibt weitere ideen für erstens
videos in die kommentare bin ich immer
sehr sehr froh darüber wenn ihr uns
fleißig macht man im sommer haben da ist
alex wie das war ist haben wir sehen uns
morgen um 19 uhr